so i've got four cartesian coordinates
here this first one is minus one
zero i tried to draw them ahead of time
so minus one zero is this point right
there i'll do it in this these new
colors the next point is zero one which
is going to be 0 1 which is that point
right there then the next point is 1 2
1 2 which is that point right up there
and then the last point
is 2 1
2 1 which is this point
that point there now my goal in this
video is to find some line y equals mx
plus b that is e that goes through these
points now the first thing let's say hey
sal there is not going to be any line
that goes through these points and you
can see that immediately you could find
a line that maybe goes through these
points but it's not going to go through
this point over here if you try to make
a line that go through these two points
it's not going to go through those
points there so you're not going to be
able to find a solution that goes
through those points but let's at least
find let's set up the equation that we
know we can't find the solution to and
maybe we can use our least squares
approximation to find a line that's
almost that almost goes through all of
these points or is at least the best
approximation for a line that goes
through those points so this first one i
can express my line sort of y equals mx
plus b let me just express it as f of x
is equal to mx plus b or y is equal to f
of x we could write it like that way
so our first point right there let me do
it in that color and that orange that
tells us that f
f of minus 1 which is equal to m times
let me just write this way minus 1 times
m so it's minus m plus b
that that is going to be equal to zero
that's what that first equation tells us
the second equation
tells us that f of zero
f of zero which is equal to 0 times m
which is just 0
plus b
is equal to
1. f of 0 is 1.
right this is the x this is f of x
the next one let me do it in this yellow
color tells us that f of one
f of one
is which is equal to one times m which
or just m
plus b
is going to be equal to two
and then this last one down here tells
us that f of 2
f of 2
is which is of course 2 times m 2 times
m
plus b that that is going to be equal to
1. these are the constraints if we
assume that our line can go through all
of these points then all of these things
must be true now you can immediately you
can if you wish try to solve this
equation but you'll find that you won't
find a solution
we want to find some m's and b's that
satisfy
all of these equations
or another way of writing this we want
to write it as a matrix vector or matrix
equation
we could write it like this
minus 1
0 1
1 1
times
the vector
times the vector
m b
has got to be equal to
has got to be equal to the vector 0 1 2
0 1 2 1.
these two systems this system and this
system right here are equivalent
statements right minus 1 times m plus 1
times b has got to be equal to that 0. 0
times m plus 1 times b has to go equal
to that one that's equivalent to this
statement right here
and this isn't going to have a solution
the solution would have to go through
all of those points so let's at least
let's at least try to find a least
square solution so if we call this a
if we call that a
if we call that x
unless you call this b
there is no solution
no solution
to
a x is equal to b
now maybe we can find a least square we
can definitely find a least square
solution so let's find
so let's
find
our least square solution such that
a transpose a times our least squares
solution is equal to a
times b our least squared solution is
the one that satisfies this equation we
proved it two videos ago so let's figure
out what a transpose a is and what a
transpose b is and then we can solve
so a transpose so a transpose will look
like this
be minus 1 1
0 1
1 1
and then 2 1.
this first column becomes this first row
the second column becomes the second row
so we're going to take the product of a
transpose and then a a is that thing
right there minus 1 0 1
2 and then we just get a bunch of ones
so what is this equal to we have a 2 by
4 times a 4 by 2 so we're going to have
a 2 by 2
matrix
2 by 2 matrix so this is going to be
let's see do it this way well we're
going to have minus 1 times minus 1
which is 1. plus zero times zero
which is zero so we're at one right now
plus one times one so that's one plus
the other one up there so that's two
plus two times two two times two is 4 so
we get 6
so it's equal to
6.
that's that row dotted with that column
was equal to 6.
now let's take this row
dotted with this column
so it's going to be negative 1 times 1
plus 0 times 1. so all of these guys
times 1 plus each other so minus 1 plus
0 plus 1 that's all 0 so it's going plus
2 so it's going to get a 2.
i just dotted that guy with that guy
now i need to take the dot of this guy
with this column so it's just going to
be 1 times minus 1 plus 1 times 0 plus 1
times 1 plus 1 times 2. well these are
all 1 times everything so it's minus 1
plus 0 plus 1 which is zero plus two so
it's going to be
two
and then finally
finally and i think you see some
symmetry here we're gonna have to take
the dot of this guy and this guy over
here so what is that that's one times
one which is one plus one times one
which is two plus one times one so we're
gonna have one plus itself four times so
we're gonna get it's equal to four so
this is a transpose
a transpose a and let's figure out what
a transpose b looks like let's scroll
down a little bit
so a transpose is this matrix again let
me switch colors
minus 1 0 1 2 we get all of our ones
just like that and then the matrix
b
is
the matrix b is 0 1 2 1 0 1
1. we have a 2 by 4 times a 4 by 1 so
we're just going to get a 2 by 1 matrix
so this is going to be equal to a 2 by 1
matrix
we have here see minus 1 times 0 is 0
plus 0 times 1 is still 0 plus 1 times 2
which is 2 plus 2 times 1 which is
4 right this is 2 plus 2 so it's going
to be 4
right there and then we have
1 times 0 plus 1 times 2 plus 1 so all 1
times all of these guys added up so zero
plus one is one one plus two is three
three plus one is four
so this right here is a
transpose b so just like that
we know that the the least square
solution will be the solution to this
system 6 2
2 4
times our least squares solution
is going to be equal to
4 4.
or we could write it this way we could
write it
6 2 2 4
times our least square solution which
i'll write remember the first entry was
m i'll write it as m star that's our
least square m and this is our least
square b
is equal to
4 4
and i could do this as an augmented
matrix or i could just write this as a
to a system of two unknowns which is
actually probably easier so let's do it
that way so this if i were to write it
as a system of equations is
6 times m star
plus 2 times v star right 6 times m star
plus 2 times b star is equal to
is equal to 4
and then i get 2 times m star 2 times m
star plus 4 times b star or times b star
is equal to this 4
is equal to that 4. so let me start
solve for my m stars and my b stars
so let's let's multiply this second
equation actually let's multiply that
top equation by 2.
this is a straight algebra 1. so times 2
what do we get we get 12
m star
plus four
v star is equal to eight just multiply
that top guy by two
now
let us
well let's multiply
let's multiply this
magenta one by negative one so this
becomes a minus this becomes a minus
that becomes a minus and now we can add
these two equations
so we get minus 2 plus 12 m star that's
m star
and then the minus 4b and the 4b cancel
out is equal to
4 or
m star is equal to 4 over 10 which is
equal to 2 fifths
now we can just go and back substitute
into this we could say 6 times m star
this is just straight algebra 1. so 6
times our m star so 6 times 2 over 5
plus 2 times our b star
is equal to 4.
not white let me use yellow so we get 12
over 5 plus 2
b star is equal to
or we could say 2
b star let me scroll down a little bit
2 b star is equal to 4 which is the same
thing as 20 over 5
minus 12 over 5 which is equal to i'm
just subtracting the 12 over 5 from both
sides which is equal to eight over five
and you divide both sides equation by
two you get b star is equal to
four
fifths and just like that we got our m
star and our b star
our least squares solution
is equal to
two-fifths
and four-fifths
so m is equal to two-fifths and b is
equal to four-fifths and remember the
whole point of this was to find an
equation of the line
y is equal to mx plus b
now we can't find a line that went
through all of those points up there
that went through all of these points
but this is going to be our least square
solution this is our this is the one
that minimizes the distance between a
between
between a times
our vector and b when no vector when you
multiply it times that matrix a
not that's not a that's a star a
transpose a
no other solution
is going to give us a closer solution to
b than when we put our newly found x
star into this equation this is going to
give us our best solution it's going to
minimize the distance to b
so let's write it out a is equal to mx
plus a y is equal to mx plus b so y is
equal to
two-fifths x
plus two-fifths let's graph that out
y is equal to two-fifths x plus
two-fifths
y is equal to two-fifths x plus two
fifths
so its y-intercept is two-fifths
which is about there this is at one
two-fifths is right about there and then
it's slope is two-fifths so
for every let's think of it this way for
every two and a half you go to the right
you're going to go up one so if we go
if we go one two and a half
we're going to go up 1. we're going to
go up 1 like that so our line and
obviously i'm this isn't precise but our
line is going to look something like
this our line is going to look
our line is going to look something like
something like this i want to do my best
shot at drawing it because this is the
fun part
it's going to look something like that
and that right there is my least squares
estimate for a line that goes through
all of those points and you're not going
to find a line that gets you kind of
that minimizes the error in a better way
at least when you measure the error is
the distance between
this vector and the vector a times our
least squares estimate anyway thought
you would find that neat